oh I know oh no no no
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by Kid Cudi he's a
Grammy award-winning artist multi-hyphen
Entertainer and true to form he just
dropped a brand new album accompanied by
an animated TV special of the same name
it's called Intergalactic check out the
album wherever you get your music and
watch the special which is now currently
streaming on Netflix Kid Cudi welcome to
the show thanks for having me man I feel
like this is one of those shoots been
that's been literally years in the
making yeah what's going through your
head as you finally prepare to take on
the hot ones gauntlet
I'm confident that I would make it to
the end you know but I have no idea what
I want to experience on this journey I'm
really uh really kind of nervous
I'm not gonna lie
[Music]
[Music]
yeah let's do it
no
I can eat more if I want right
go ahead and I'll follow you right along
with
oh good
oh my God
nice so dating back to the original man
on the moon your albums have always had
a cinematic Sonic quality to them so I
can only imagine how cathartic it must
have been for you to take Intergalactic
and then actually storyboard it out for
an animated adaptation and then costume
design it's not a discipline that you'd
often associate with animation but it
really is at the heart of
intergalactic's aesthetic what role did
Virgil ablo play in shaping the fashion
of this world well um it was really like
I put it all on him you know I really
went into this knowing that like I
wanted the characters to be fresh I
didn't want it to be like you know a
typical animated show where you see one
character wearing the same thing every
episode you know Virgil came through and
just put his magic sauce on it and just
made you know wardrobe for each
character in it that matched their
personality I was so like happy because
I was like oh my God like this is the
best idea I could ever came up with you
know we could have been
could have been in this and making some
really shitty clothing you know but I
have like the illest freshest
[ __ ] alive doing this [ __ ] for
me and it's in and it was just it was
just the illest man and I love him to
death of that you know
[Music]
yeah these first two I need them to go
so in the a man named Scott documentary
playing Pats as a first working with you
it was so different and weird that I'd
feel uncomfortable but I love it was
there a watershed moment maybe it was a
song maybe it was a show where it went
from this sort of experimental Bohemian
exercise to all of a sudden record
labels and a bidding war for you I think
I think it was the mixtape
because the mixtape was playful and fun
and it was just all about like showing
people I could rap and
you know the album was like
no this is like the Oscar nominated
version of an album you know I live with
DOT for almost three years and during
this time we were making music and made
day and night and a number of other
records and from there and then we we
added a meal and then it was just like
when I had those three guys I was I was
golden and I liked even hearing from a
meal when he was talking about how he'd
play you beats that he prepared but you
wouldn't really react to those things it
wasn't until he would just be like
playing Ascent or like pulling out old
records yeah I mean that's because you
know that's the that's the [ __ ] that was
like the type of Records he would play
you know were always like
interesting and like weird you know and
that was you know my [ __ ] like I just
wanted something that didn't sound like
the typical [ __ ] that you would hear in
hip-hop you know like with ghosts like
you hear ghosts you hear that sample I
was like what the [ __ ] you know like and
ghost is still to this day like one of
my top three favorite songs
you're crushing it are you ready to move
on to Wing number three this is Pico
Rico here and you're doing great
um
these first three I'm good but I see
when I get down to here it's probably
gonna get real
so even as your music career exploded
you've still remained a prolific actor
and earlier this year it was announced
that you'd be making your directorial
debut in an upcoming Netflix project
called Teddy what's the best audition
tip or note that you've ever gotten from
Timothy chalman I think I asked him
about crying on camera once
you know I've given him like audition
tapes that I've done before and I'm just
like hell man shoot me straight you know
he's always like oh it's good it's good
he's like I don't know he could be lying
to me uh but he's always he's always
very supportive in in um I know Timmy is
a fan of me for music but I you know I
think he's a fan of me as an actor as
well
my lips are tingling well
a whole lot more is about to happen as
we work our way down but first things
first the hot ones barbacoa
foreign
[Music]
I'm a two bite kind of guy
I respect it I know you do the same
thing I do so I'm trying to
test you I know you're testing me
pushing me yeah who knows maybe you'll
be the only one standing by the end of
this I mean maybe I'm ready but you do
this you do this all the time you do
this on a rig I know right but at some
point I'm gonna hit that wall right I
mean at some point you're gonna be like
I'm tired of fire poopies and you're
just gonna say like that's what I'm
gonna ask you after this man sure you
can ask me during whatever you know this
can be this can go both ways because
your brows are probably like what the
[ __ ] you know what's fascinating is your
body adjusts
this long I'll go to Equinox after this
you know what I mean like oh no way I'm
unstoppable I'm unstoppable I mean who
knows like I don't want to get
overconfident it's like an athlete you
know like I think you probably have a
physical prime and then you know maybe
the wings will start to slow me down but
right now I'm good right now God age
like Brady over here yeah I was like
Sean has a stomach of Steel Man straight
up
[Music]
okay here we go
it's crunchy foreign
do I always have to take two bites you
know you make the rules over here you're
making the rules over here I'm just
following along with you
I'm just hungry so I came in here
starving
um I don't know if that was a good idea
I could cut you every crane segment on
our show called explain that gram we're
gonna do a deep dive in our guest
Instagram interesting pictures that need
more context and for you we have a theme
it's a Kid Cudi style retrospective so
what we've done is we've pulled some of
our favorite Kid Cudi fit picks and
we're just curious how you react how you
reflect looking back on those things now
oh my God all right laptop please Bill
there we go bring it back a laptop very
rare thank you very much
do you have a favorite memory from
walking at the Palais Royal Gardens for
Virgil ablo's first Louis Vuitton
collection yes I do
it just didn't feel real you know the
whole thing was just like
you know like a dream you know
um and I was soaking it up so much that
like uh I was walking really slow on the
on the on the runway so like you can't
see in this picture like there's like
all those people stacked up behind me
that's a trapping Champion
that's why this person's got this good
ass photo because it was like no it was
like
20 feet between me and the other dude in
front of me like it's like right there
but uh I was just uh I was really high
and I was just soaking it up man I was
like this is a beautiful moment so yeah
what's the biggest difference between
working at a vape store and working at
Abercrombie and Fitch and then how did
each shape your personal style working
at the Abercrombie and fish store
the clothes sucked and it wasn't like it
wasn't like I was like
proud to be wearing Abercrombie and
Fitch like their jeans were all right I
guess they're just right I guess but
when I worked at the base sword that was
the first time I was like oh man like
this is like actually some fresh [ __ ]
but like you know I was so poor when I
got that job
so I didn't own any bait prior to
working there so uh I literally had the
same brown bathing Aid t-shirt and these
jeans and these yellow uh Roasters and I
had that for like two months that outfit
I used to ask my co-workers if I could
borrow some of their clothes and they
would hold me down and let me borrow a
hoodie or two and working at that store
was was like
was like the greatest to me and at that
time like it was bigger than getting a
record deal yeah you know like
and I really wanted the record just that
time you know but it was like oh [ __ ] I
got the baby store I'm good you know
like it just it just it was such a major
thing because of what it meant to the
culture and what it was Nigo came to the
store with the Teriyaki boys one time
and I met them fast forward all the
years later when we did the the complex
magazine cover so it was like this full
circle moment you know just being around
the God you know it was so cool man so
cool
Bill thank you very much
I gotta get one of those hot ones
t-shirts too we got you put it put it in
his to-go bag with the sauces all right
and I wanted to go wings too there you
go do we have extras the first four we
gotta hit that Rider we gotta hit that
Rider Kid Cudi are you ready to move on
here to the back half already you're
doing great I'm gonna yeah I'm gonna
waiting for this [ __ ] to get real now
it's not it hasn't gotten real yet it's
gonna like you know a little kick it but
it's not crazy
this is the sea turmeric bomb
see if this does it for you I mean this
[ __ ] is like green
this [ __ ] looks wrong
[Music]
oh my God I'm not gonna take two bites
yes it's
um I don't know
I'm holding down
hip-hop icons like Jay-Z Nas Eminem and
Snoop are often credited as being the
first generation of rap Superstars to
really show that they can age along with
the genre I've heard you talk about how
you don't want to be performing on stage
late into your 40s but I'm curious are
there people that you see as paradigms
for what it looks like to age as an
artist to you
yeah like um
Jay-Z for sure you know
um but I I feel like I don't have what
they have
and explain I don't I just don't
I just don't know if I want to if I want
to do
uh if I want to just do music drop
albums for too much longer you know I'm
kind of nearing the end on on all things
Kid Cudi I think
it sounds like kind of breaking news
yeah yeah yeah I'm really curious to see
what else I can do
I was thinking about this and this is
like a a wacky idea I had years ago
but like it would be cool to like one
day like be a kindergarten teacher you
know just do that for like a couple
years like when I'm like 50 you know
just like for like 10 years I was a
kindergarten teacher you know and I just
like infect the youth with that
freshness like you can get them young
and then just those kids will just
sprinkle the freshness to the world and
I'll just be like yes
[Laughter]
[Music]
Cosmic Disco
sounds like my playback
foreign
[Music]
a second bite
no
[Music]
it's that time
[Music]
just happens like this I know
I'm following your lead to the
strawberry oh my God oh my God
no
I'm on the topic of cosmic disco what do
you mean when you describe the style of
your music is space punk rock what was
that repeat the question sweet Jesus
space punk rock I've heard you describe
your style of music as space punk rock
yeah
it's baseball bro
[Laughter]
space punk rock yes that's that damn
[ __ ]
oh man uh
super synthy but Reckless and dangerous
and edgy
if aliens visited Earth and all you were
armed with was a Kid Cudi playlist to
greet the encounter which Kid Cudi song
would you have as a way to you know make
sure Humanity stays in the aliens good
graces embrace the Martian embrace the
Martian
notice how from the second you said that
you were waiting for it it came you know
it's like you
you asked for it Scott
you asked for it
[Music]
oh my God
oh my God
oh my God
and that's immediately
in outer space
men on the moon over here
[Music]
there's some [ __ ]
yo man yeah
this one is [ __ ] up yeah
100 these are these last two like this
kind of like that
so it's gonna be telling you the truth
oh my God nothing is like this no okay
okay it's like this sauce oh my God [ __ ]
foreign
so when we had Seth Rogen on the show he
said that thick patties are for
[ __ ] as a cheeseburger connoisseur
yourself do you agree or disagree on
that big patties
big patties for [ __ ]
um
huh
oh my God
see the water soothes better
so science would tell you that the water
makes things worse yeah but I find that
there's something and maybe it's
psychological about the ice cold water
it's kind of soothing to me yeah I think
science is wrong on this one this makes
it like I feel like I can get through
I feel like I could get through with the
water the milkshake
the milkshake wasn't doing [ __ ]
milkshake was just like delicious but
like still like on fire my [ __ ] nose
is running oh my God sweet Jesus where
do you fall on ketchup on a burger yay
or nay on that yeah I mean I'm the type
of person
that puts a ridiculous amount of ketchup
on a burger so much so like when you put
the top bun on it just runs off the
sides you know check my favorite thing
to do
oh my God
pucker butt
it's a show I have to apologize for you
know okay here we go
so
nothing fun about this one but I think
after the last one
I know
I know
do this
is a nightmare I thought it was gonna be
fun talking to you about [ __ ]
man
I asked saiya if you get the the fire
shits after this he said no so that's
good right and I'm telling you no two
we're good we're good we're good as bad
as it is right now that's the worst it's
gonna be oh my God so I once heard you
Muse about wanting to go on a bar
mitzvah tour because you find them to be
so fun exactly and lucrative what is the
sickest Bar Mitzvah that you've ever
performed at oh my God the very first
one the very first apartment and and
they they paid me 30 grand
to do three songs
I come out and I do a song and the kids
are all excited I was there and I was
having a moment and they were like
taking pictures and I was like wow I
feel like it's like early on in my
career so I was just like oh my God
these kids make me feel more famous than
I ever felt before in my life you know
and then
after that I was like okay
I've always wanted this Rolex a
presidential day day right
I I totally was like okay I'm gonna take
this money
and I'm gonna go buy this Rolex
so that's and I still have that Rolex I
still wear it to this day and um it was
it was a great buy it was one of the it
was one of my most important buys
because it was like first off I really
really really really wanted that that
watch
and I was dreaming about it before I had
money and then I finally got it and I
was like oh man this is so cool you know
and you have that first bar mitzvah to
thank for it yeah oh my God
um
goddamn
[Music]
my jibs are on fire right now Sean
foreign
[Music]
you know let me put a little extra oh
[Music]
see that I see that I see that I'm
following suit okay
okay
just for all the marbles cheers get
Cuddy cheers what a ride yeah
[Music]
I know
oh I know
my God
oh
I know I know but the good news hid
Cutty is we have reached the end of our
hot ones Gauntlet and just one more ball
to balance on your nose before we roll
credits what the [ __ ] else you want
you've hummed better Melodies than most
artists have ever written and fans know
that you can transform a whole song
without even using a word so what I'll
do to close things out is I'll point at
a sauce and you just hum the first
feeling that it evokes when you think
about what it was like to eat that sauce
okay
all right up first fly by jig
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
to bomb Beyond insanity
[Music]
was that good that was so good looks
like we have another hit on our hands
and look at you Kid Cudi taking on the
hot ones Gauntlet calling your shot
making it all the way to the end now
there's nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you this camera this
camera this camera let the people know
what you have going on in your life I
got this [ __ ] show Intergalactic
coming out next week oh look I mean it's
out now I don't know when you guys are
airing this uh
got a bunch of stuff going on just stay
tuned stay tuned
[Applause]
oh
I made it through though you bodied it I
did and no one can take that away from
you no one can take that [ __ ] away from
me Sean no one no one
they can kiss my ass
oh my God
that wins fans thank you so much for
watching
what if you want to get your hands on
the season 19 hot Ones hot sauce
Gauntlet boy do I have good news for you
just visit heatness.com heatness.com
that's heatness.com to get your hands on
the 10 pack the season 19 hot ones 10
pack hot ones in a box delivered right
to your door I highly recommend it it's
delicious I eat it every week
[Music]